les sept pays les plus riches de la
planète et 45 entreprises parmi les plus
performantes mondialement ont
rendez-vous ce week-end à bruxelles pour
un g7 peu ordinaire consacrée aux
autoroutes de l'information autrement
dit à des réseaux de télécommunication à
très haut débit
un enjeu technologique et économique
considérable puisque la seule industrie
des télécommunications devrait peser
plus de 4500 milliards de francs en l'an
2000 et créer des millions d'emplois à
travers le monde à bruxelles pour france
2 christian marie monnet ceux du réseau
ce fut ni les embouteillages la voiture
de demain sera intelligente elle vous
donnera les informations pratiques en
temps réel c'est une des applications
les autoroutes de l'information les
américains affichent leur avance et à
partir de votre télévision
vous pourrez faire vos achats en direct
ainsi quatre mille foyers sont équipés
en floride
tout le monde peut faire la même chose
dans son pays
comme les américains les français se
cherche encore cette pme a conçu un
logiciel de bandes dessinées et
commandes sont encore rares et les
banques et n'y crois pas du tout propos
commercial on est très présent dans les
chais les majors ça los angeles mais on
a fait je pense une erreur de chercher
deux capitales au fossé un nouvel outil
va envahir l'europe internet créé par
l'armée américaine
le minitel version universelle rapide
mondial peu cher et permet de gérer son
temps de travail
l'intérêt de cet outil c'est qu'on peut
l'utiliser professionnellement d'une
manière extrêmement efficace travailler
depuis chez soi à la campagne et puis
avoir une bonne qualité de vie à partir
de 200 sont utilisation
la maîtrise de cet outil cette société
de la formation total va-t-elle
permettre des créations d'emplois et
améliorer la qualité de la vie à l'aube
du troisième millénaire jessel
n'apportera pas de réponse mais les
américains y croit les européens sont
plus sceptiques